anh alo chào các bạn ờ ờ
[âm nhạc]
đang thấy không lên à
Các bạn thấy màn hình mày chưa Ừ rồi
mình mới thấy rồi Ờ
Ừ anh khỏe Được bao nhiêu phần trăm
gà mấy ông để dọn tôi thì sao là cũng
biết mà à
alo ờ béo để giọng Tôi sợ anh biết mà à
hai kỳ lạ tôi một người rất thích bơi
nhưng không hiểu sao hai lần gần nhất đi
bơi đều ốm một lần thì à Đừng có vịt
không nói lần thứ hai này không bị dính
nhưng mà vẫn uống
ở thời kỳ lạ
nhưng mà khi hết ốm thôi sẽ vẫn tiếp tục
đi bơi tiếp không gì ngăn cản được Đam
Mê
Hôm nay thì các bạn thấy tiêu đề nó sẽ
là hôm nay mình sẽ là bảo vệ thủ về hôm
trước mình bị ốm
buổi trước nữa thì không nhớ là nghỉ vì
lý do gì như thế thôi không nhớ lần cuối
dãy email hôm nào cảm thấy rõ là xa xôi
rồi thì
Nhưng nói chung và hôm nay sẽ là hôm nay
sẽ bảo vệ thôi Nếu mà nếu mà những nhóm
làm à Hôm nay vẫn chưa bảo vệ được thì
thứ năm thì tôi sẽ
thứ năm thì nhóm nào muốn bảo vệ thử nữa
Hoa Cà
chứ không phải mỗi thứ 5 mà các hôm khác
thì mình vẫn khuyến khích các bạn bảo vệ
thử nhé Không sao cả Còn không thì bắt
đầu từ thứ 5 sẽ là sẽ sẽ là mình sẽ
hướng dẫn các bạn làm lại tài liệu đã cả
bắt đầu ngồi chấm tài liệu Nếu như ông ạ
Nói chung là gần như cốt thì bây giờ các
bạn phải tương đối khá là ông để mà chạy
được rồi Nói chung bây giờ mà cốt với
chị đầy đủ tính năng thêm giờ xóa thì
thì nó
không không đủ
ở trong và bây giờ bắt buộc phải có tính
năng quan trọng tính năng ra tính năng
nghiệp vụ rồi
à à
Ừ ừ hôm nay sẽ bảo vệ thử Nên là các
nhóm mà nhưng mà bảo vệ thử ở đây sẽ chị
bảo vệ vẫn chưa chắc là chưa cần tài
liệu cốt là kiểu đêm Ngô tính năng thôi
nghĩa là này các nhóm Hôm nay
muốn demo tính năng
Ừ Ok chị ạ
ờ ờ ờ
lại tội không nhớ được là tôi sẽ tâm sự
với cái gì nữa chắc là này bỏ qua điện à
à
à à
vụ này đó là
thế hôi mà có bao giờ các bạn tự So sánh
bản thân mình với hồi cấp 2 thậm chí hồi
cấp 1 không ạ theo kiểu là như này
hồi cấp 1 và cấp 2 có một Tôi là chuyên
toán nghe vẫn cảm thấy sai sai sai cấp 2
tôi chuyên cả Toán cả lý lý ở đây là Vật
lý địa lý luôn sinh rất nhiều cái cấp 3
thì tôi là học sinh trung bình sẽ Thằng
Kiên cái gì cả
thì lúc đấy thôi cứ so sánh mình với bạn
thân mình về quá khứ đó là
Đó là kiểu hòa mình đang ngu dần đi ra
sao nghĩa cả thế
ờ ờ nên là
Ừ
thế là kiểu tôi hôm đấy Tôi tưởng ai cập
Thấy à Cậu bản thân mình đang Hình như
ngày càng ngu đi nếu mà nếu mà mình kéo
chăm học hay không hẳn là chăm học đâu
hồi cấp 1 cấp 2 tôi không hẳn là chăm
đâu nhưng mà chỗ ngồi đấy tôi cảm thấy à
cậu có vẻ đã ạ từ
tư duy nhanh nhạy hơn còn mà một các bà
như dính vào lưới Tinh à xong rồi dính
vào nhiều Cám Dỗ hơn kết hợp được cha
gặp toàn có nhiều người ta vẫn luôn vân
vẫn nhiều như tối tao động để khiến cho
mình kiểu đấy là học sinh trung bình để
kiểu thế
Ừ thôi cấp 1 Tôi có nó không nhiều loại
lắm nhưng mà điểm tôi rất là cao chỉ có
môn văn là điểm thấp nhất thôi tất cả
điểm muốn khác đều K cấp 1 gồm nói nha
nhưng hồi cấp hai nó sẽ thứ ba lớp tôi
cũng được trong đội tuyển đi thi học
sinh giỏi toán A đúng đúng học sinh giỏi
nhưng theo kiểu thế cho tôi còn trốn đi
thi để mà đi nét nhưng mà nó trong và
mình vẫn là nằm trong top Cá thứ
còn cấp 3 thì link rồi học sinh trung
bình sẽ thứ 20 lớp tôi còn chẳng nhớ giữ
xếp như nào nhưng mà tại khá thì đúng là
hồi các bà thôi cũng học chỉ những môn
mình quan trọng thôi ghi âm chưa vẫn học
vẫn học dàn trải tính tôi vẫn thấy mô
nào cũng cần thiết để học nhưng ý rồi là
tôi không quan trọng cái gì ạ điểm số
thành tích lắm nữa hồi cấp hai con điểm
số thành tích tiêu kiểu là của học sinh
giỏi để mà kiểu được cộng điểm đi cấp 3
thì cần gì thì thành ra kiểu cũng hơi
xóa Ê hồi đấy thôi công nhận là tôi càng
ngày tôi càng ý
tất cả ngày cắm Thế cậu mình khiến cho
bản thân mình não mình bị lười đi nên
thành ra à tư duy đã bị chậm đi
từ lúc vậy tôi cũng không muốn là kẻ
mình nếu thế Mình phải học chưa toán lại
để mà mình sẽ tư duy à Không cho đến cái
hồi mà tôi làm học lập trình này thì
đúng đúng là học lập trình là để mà kiểu
Tôi cảm thấy là tôi bắt đầu à Nếu mà so
với trước khi học lập trình đến bây giờ
là
cho tôi thì tôi thông minh lên rất nhiều
cái toàn bộ các câu nói của tôi có lô
gic hơn và chặt chẽ hơn khó bị bắt bẻ
Vân Anh
anh không những là mình tư duy được lập
trình nhé Mà nó rèn tư duy cảm ngoài đời
sống để kiếm cho cách xử lý tình huống
mọi thứ của tôi cảm thấy à mình thông
minh mình đang thông minh dần lên nếu
các bạn để ý kĩ là dân công nghệ thường
hay thế nếu mà mai mà tôi cảm thấy tôi
ít ra tôi bớt máy móc hơn nhiều dân công
nghệ hoặc các tôi chưa đủ thông minh và
Họ nên họ máy móc ở đây tôi không biết
nhưng mà hôm trước tôi cũng xem một cái
Ừ cái này là quan điểm của một người
Thật ra tôi cho có điện versailles đấy
nó sao người ta bảo là thực ra thì
ở người người hơi hơi thông minh thì họ
nói khó hiểu còn họ còn người cực kỳ
thông minh thì họ lại nói rất là dễ nghe
bởi vì khi họ đã quá tường người điều
đấy thì họ sẽ biết cách nói sao cho nó
dễ hiểu cái này thì tôi không tin nó
hoàn toàn lắm Nói thế thì anh tang nói
cho anh chưa đủ thông minh bởi vì hồi
anh tang giải thích cái thuyết của mấy
chỉ có hai người hai người sống trong
cái ở
lễ hội đồng khoa học hiểu thì phải nhớ
Thế à
thế nhưng đại khái Thì ý tôi đó là hợp
lập trình có thể bạn không khéo cái
thành lập trình Nhưng mà tôi thấy là hợp
lập trình cơ bản về cơ bản nó ngoài để
cho các bạn hiểu qua thế nên là lập
trình hiểu qua không ngại về công nghệ
thông tin Vân thì đúng là nó có rèn tư
duy một tí nó vẫn rèn tư duy đấy do mà
là
kiểu bên nước ngoài và bên nước ngoài
như ở cho học lập trình nhưng mà lập
trình theo kiểu dùng splash đấy các bạn
biết cái này nữa
I
thả để nó sẽ ra cho ít nó không cần
giống như nó cũng kiểu đó là ngôn ngữ
lập trình bởi vì nó cũng kéo ít theo có
vòng lọc các thứ để mà chạy cái này có
thể biến thành một cái gì chuyển động
cho đến chơi trò chơi Vân chạy thoát
khỏi mê cung của Vân hay phết
đề thi Ừ cái đấy ở bên nước ngoài người
ta áp dụng cho kiểu học sinh tiểu học có
để mà kiểu gen tư duy
giá là hay thế tôi nghĩa là cậu học
chương trình về cơ bản thì nó để dành
cho Duy nó vẫn có cái hay Và thậm chí
nếu mà bạn dùng mấy cái này ấy kiểu để
mà Đấy và xử lý những cái gì đó thì các
bạn hình dung được rèn tư duy Tôi thấy
nó còn hay và thiết thực hơn so với các
bạn học toán
Ừ đúng ạ Nếu các bạn nôi toán là đứng
như toán tôi không phủ tôi không phủ
nhận về toán nó dành tư duy vào toán nó
cần thiên nga nhưng với ông nào bảo toàn
không cần thiết thì thì quá say luôn đấy
nhưng mà tí thôi à
từ hồi cấp 1 mà ông ngoại ông ngoại học
Việt Nam mình nhỉ đúng ạ châu á Nói
chung thì đúng rồi chú trọng toán bị lý
thuyết nhiều quá thành ra là cửa
các nước khác
ý nghĩa là hỏi ví dụ là các bạn có đọc
cái đấy chưa Tôi không biết tôi vẫn chỉ
đọc qua mạng nha này chưa thực tế là
trên thực tế nào nhưng mà để lại ấn
tượng so sánh và toàn cấp 2 của mình
bằng Toán đại học ở bên Mỹ chẳng hạn như
thế nghĩa là Nghĩa hồi cấp 2 mình đã học
những cái khó có thể thứ đúng là để dành
thứ gì có nhưng mà để khiến người ta
mạng cũng có bởi vì cảm thấy nó không
thiết thực thì tôi Nghĩa học lập trình
mi kiểu kiểu các bạn lại không phải
Pascal không phải suy nghĩ gì cả thì
đúng điều dùng mấy cái kiểu ngày hợp cho
trẻ con đấy thì nó cũng là một cái khá
là hay không xa ít béo hoặc nạp nó thứ
để khiến con này chuyển động thôi Chẳng
hạn khi gặp cái vất cảm thì nó rẽ rồi
chị ạ nhưng cái mơ hồ nhưng mà Mấy ông
làm giải mấy cái bài đó thoát khỏi mê
cung đi Thì cũng sẽ dễ hiểu hơn có thể
làm việc game đấy nhá làm game chứ kéo
giống kiểu nó có mặc định chạy Xong rồi
thấy cũng tất cả nó nhảy lên đi nếu mà
nhảy được thì nó sẽ còn sống con nếu mà
đâm trúng thì nó sẽ chết giống kiểu công
viên khủng long ấy
tivi cũng được khá hay
mình xin phép chia sẻ tí cái này cũng
không phải thông tin mật thì chị sẽ được
đó là hôm trước là tôi rồi
Ừ cái này nó sẽ đưa hai quyết định nhá
Hôm trước tôi qua FPT academy tại học
viện của bên FPT Shop sẽ que thì để tôi
phỏng vấn này mà tôi định là tháng 10
này tôi sẽ về bên đấy Dậy Thì thì rất là
bên đấy Đúng ở không có cái môn thôi
đang dạy đó muốn TP thì nên là
bên đấy đang xem xét xem mà xem tôi dậy
như thế nào thôi Chưa được dậy thử để mà
xem có phù hợp để mà mở hành khóa mới
được TP không
Ừ nhưng mà khi mà họ xem qua thử tôi dạy
atwell ở trên kênh của tôi thì
Ừ thì chắc là họ cảm thấy là tôi dậy lý
thuyết không đủ nhiều
Ê bà cũng đúng là tôi bởi vì tôi không
chuyên lý thuyết Tôi học ở trường nghề ở
trường tôi mà nếu tôi không ăn ở trên lý
thuyết đó trên thực hành hơn chưa đủ
nhiều chưa đủ kĩ để mà thể truyền tài và
và cá nhân Tộ thấy đấy cũng được tính là
một điểm yếu của tôi vì thứ nhất là tôi
không qua một cái trường lớp sư phạm mà
cả thứ hai là lý thuyết của mình thì bản
chất là mình vẫn sẽ phụ thuộc vào cái
thực hành của mình và đọc thêm 1 tí da
liễu chứ không có một cái bài bản nào cả
để không không phải là nó bởi vì hồi tôi
học vui nộm chỉ có thế thôi tôi dậy mày
ông là tôi có dậy hơn cả những cái mà
hồi tôi đã học rồi đấy nhưng mà nó vẫn
có vẻ chưa đủ Nó chỉ áp dụng được thực
hành từ đấy mà tự mò thêm chứ lý thuyết
là vẫn còn thiếu ấy thì tôi
cho tôi biết được là bên họ mang dáng
thế thì tôi chắc là tôi sẽ phải học một
khóa ở bên đấy để xem cách họ dạy cũng
như ở bổ sung thêm kiến thức bản thân ý
nghĩa là thử ta cũng đối Lúc đầu thì
cũng bị ngậy cả cũng tự ti theo kiểu là
Ý bạn là em mình lúc đầu mình cắt tự tin
là mình sẽ có thể đi dạy được luôn bây
giờ có hóa là cũng phải mình phải kiểu
bổ sung thêm kiến thức phải học thêm một
khóa nữa để để làm mà trợ giảng đã xong
rồi sau đó thì mới làm giảm viên Huỳnh
Đức cơ nhưng mà không sao bởi vì à về cơ
bản thì tôi còn định là 30 tuổi thôi bắt
đầu với dậy Chứ không phải bây giờ Bây
giờ tính ra nếu mà tôi ở tuổi dương thì
chắc mình chỉ có hai năm rồi vẫn còn
vẫn còn kiểu truyền võng còn còn rất
nhiều thời gian để ở mình nhà mình cải
thiện bản thân trước trước cái gốc đấy
ấy thì tôi nghĩa là tôi sẽ học khóa để
mà sẽ nói chung là rèn kỹ năng sư phạm
nữa về tôi cũng phải cần thi cái chứng
chỉ sư phạm nữa rồi còn chưa có một khí
và cho qua một cái trường lớp gì cả để
để mà
Ừ bia về kỹ năng sư phạm hay gì gì đó
đồng nghĩa tới nó dậy vì cái tâm và
những cái gì chia sẻ được thì chia sẻ
nhưng nó chưa có một sự bài đoạn đấu họ
chưa sự muốn sự với bạn nào cả Thì đấy
là lý do đưa ra quyết định thứ hai của
tôi đó là chắc là tôi sẽ khi mà tôi qua
đấy Dậy một thời gian nếu mà còn dư giả
hơn thời gian và
anh về sau nếu mà rảnh quá hay gì đó
chắc là tôi sẽ Tôi không nghĩ định xóa
những cái Visa cũ này nhưng tôi sẽ xóa
những cái clip cũ những cái à
em lấy nick cụ trên kênh của tôi không
không sẽ video nha chị shop lấy cô và
tôi sẽ mở một khóa mới nghĩa là ít nhất
là một khóa mới cho để cho cái khóa tiếp
theo
ý nghĩa là tôi sẽ mở khóa online nữa cho
khóa sau đề mà tôi sẽ dạy lại từ đầu và
theo kiểu ai bàn hơn chuyên nghiệp hơn
theo phong cách của tệ FPT thử xem thế
nào
Ừ thì chắc là nó sẽ có hai khóa không ạ
một khóa hiện tại này và các bạn bây giờ
sắp bảo vệ thì các bạn tốt nghiệp rồi
Hòa tự khai và thực ra là đây đây đây
cũng là
ở đây cũng là kiểu dạng là tốt cho các
bạn sau hơi bị triệt các bạn Hiện tại
các bạn Hiện tại thì đang được tôi dậy
theo kiểu dạng là là kiểu như này nghỉ à
em chưa bài bạc Hãy mưa vẫn chưa đủ kiến
thức cái gì đó thì các bạn khá sau sẽ
được bài bản hơn
chị sẽ được tôi được Long phiên bản được
Ừ rồi dặn kinh nghiệm hơn để mà truyền
tải đúng ạ Các bạn qua sau sẽ được lợi
hơn tí
cho tôi Tôi đang nghĩ là như thế
thấy con nít đoán mua giới thì xem đến
đâu của web nâng cao thì coi được đoán
luôn rồi ạ
Em xem hết cái danh sách nâng cao thì
chuyển qua mua rồi nhá
ý tưởng lắm hả Thôi trách bây giờ gần
như là cái gì chẳng dùng our dùng cơ sở
liệu Thôi thì em làm trang web và tin
tức hay bán hàng cơ bản cũng được
anh FA là FPT academy đó là nếu nó dịch
ra là học viện nhưng mà
bản chất nó giống như là trường nghề đó
sẽ dạy cậu dạng là kiểu học các lớp bổ
túc kích cỡ Thế các lớp học buổi tối hay
gì đó một cái khóa ngắn hạn gì đó
Xong rồi Bên đấy ba còn đang bảo là tôi
hay là tôi chuyển qua làm kiểu giảm
chuyên gia về bên đấy Đúng rồi chuyến
dép nhiều hơn nghĩ ám chỉ là chuyện con
node.js nữa cả ra Switch back đấy giờ
tôi có phải không Tôi tôi thấy ạ Đây bây
giờ để mà học ngôn ngữ mới thì cũng được
nhưng quan trọng nó không thể chuyên
được bằng cái ngôn ngữ mình đã làm quen
lâu lắm rồi A parallel Đây là nếu mà do
chủ biên sang ngày mới thấy tôi chỉ học
để làm được thôi chứ còn để mà dậy làm
sao mà dậy được rồi kìa mình không
chuyên nó thì nếu mà sinh viên hỏi cái
gì mình sẽ có trả lời
khi họ thực ca TP vẫn đang rất là tiền
anh đấy nhá không phải là họ không nhưng
PT mà mẹ về cơ bản thì ép shop đó là đó
là
kiểu dạng công ty Apple nghĩa là nhận dự
án ở bên ngoài về để làm thì
Ừ thì những cái dự án bên nước ngoài
đúng là nó chuyên nhiều nhưng mạnh nhất
là về java và nốt chết cũng cũng có năm
ngoái hình người ta bảo là có liên quan
để razzil nhưng bây giờ thì gửi email tô
nghĩa là kiểu tràn trên mạng điện tử
bằng merantau comment với tôi thì tôi
khuyên thật thì cũng đừng đâm đầu Mentos
khi ông muốn ktp đấy thì
Ừ thì bên đấy ý thích thì vẫn có thể đào
tạo nhưng mà ý ý là sẽ phải đi tìm cái
nguồn khác để mà nhận làm dự án bồi
thường là bên đấy sẽ làm như nào bên đấy
sẽ ngoài việc đào tạo sinh viên sao một
con cam kết đầu ra sinh viên là việc cam
kết đầu ra là có thể làm lô tại F shop
mà ép shop thì bây giờ chị đang nhận
những cái dự án không có leo lên thành
ra là kiểu học xong razzil thì đúng là
không không làm được cho em shop thì sẽ
phải nhảy sang công ty khác thì một là
bây Liên kết công ti khác hay là phải
tìm thêm dự án này level dành cho sinh
viên là
thì
tại sao không đập đầu ở Mai lên to quá
toàn bộ kiến thức ông đã học của Lazio
FPT ông để trong máy ô tô thì gần như
ông Chào ứng dụng được cái gì cả đây thứ
nhất là hai đó là tê một ít thôi Còn mấy
cho tôi gần như là nó làm chỗ nào mà thứ
hai là khi móng trên mai anh đâu rồi ông
cũng chẳng ngời ông cũng chẳng ôm cái
nước đấy nhảy sang bất kỳ cái gì được
nếu bạn sanh ra ông học nào đeo ông biết
MBC và Ok đúng không cũng nhảy sang ngôn
ngữ khác Kiểu gì nó cũng có MBC và Oppa
thì thì ông còn ăn dụng được Kiểu kể cái
kính kiến thức đấy còn men tôi chẳng
không nên là thương mà Ông làm theo mà
lên câu rồi thì thì ông chỉ mang theo
magento nó gần giống nhiều làm pate lắm
thế thôi
các bạn con thích được hoạt động như thế
nào mà con thích thì cốt để mình lưu lại
những cái cấu hình các thử thứ để mà
mình sẽ lấy đồ ra để mình xử lý đã nào
giống như là cậu à con pic thì tôi
thường ngày lưu là có thể lưu dụng là
à à
ở mấy cái mình kiểu nó là hằng số ấy
mình thay vì mình lưu ở hướng cốt cái
quan trọng ở đây là để cho người dùng có
thể tự xử thế nên là mình phải lưu lại
bạc còn không Mình lưu lại code cho
nhanh chữ cái hàm số ấy rồi đặt đại khái
kiểu ông Ông kiểm tra ví dụ là ví dụ là
trong
3 Nơ làm cái ảnh đi thì đây là một cái
con fix
tiếp theo là gì ông có thể là kiểm tra
tình trạng để mà được khi là bạn ví dụ
là bình thường là
Ừ ông thể kiểm tra theo cầu loại ba buổi
muộn 24 tuổi muộn rồi tính một buổi nghỉ
hai nhà chỉ có hai buổi muộn tí ngồi
nghỉ thay ông lưu trong cốt thì cũng lưu
lại trong Con thích nói nhiều cái lắm
trong contact Nói chung là mình sẽ lưu
lại rất nhiều cái để mà mình không đều
trong thằng Trực tiếp tốt
quá có ai không đau đầu vì ra cứ đâu em
Speed vẫn gặp TP được cho là 100 Nói
chung là những ngôn ngữ bị ghét mà Bởi
vì đông người dùng đông người ghét
mày đâu em ạ - dự án rất cũ thôi Thế nên
là anh không phản hướng các bạn với lắm
tới chung là chỉ có dậy release cho các
bạn biết qua về sử dụng Isaac kiểu để
gọi đến Abi đã cả xử lý một vài cái để
các bạn hiểu qua được ra quýt có thể làm
gì thôi chứ còn Bởi vì anh đang không
chuyên về view lên thấy ra anh không dậy
một phát xong View cho mấy bạn được là
cả Bây giờ mà kết hợp cả purview thì có
kia hơi quá tải các bạn anh thấy Giữ di
dễ học lúc đầu nhưng mà đừng có nên
chuyện nó kìa không áp dụng được đâu chả
dụng từ trong trường hợp em ạ
nằm MBC nghĩa là dùng tmvc thuần nữa
không dùng Facebook
Ừ nếu mà nếu mà dùng Facebook được nếu
mà biết dùng Facebook thì vẫn dùng nhé
nên dùng nhé
ừ ừ
muốn bảo vệ à Alo mày muốn biến thành
một buổi tâm sự à
đấy thì tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ à
Ừ tôi sẽ xóa xóa cái clip không phải xóa
video nha playlist mấy cái play cái cũ
đợi khóa sau tôi sẽ xóa xong rồi tôi sẽ
dạy lại theo chuẩn có hẳn slide cho thử
tài liệu có thử thứ truyền kỳ để bảo dạy
cho khóa sau
A và sau chắc là còn đâu tháng 10 thôi
bắt đầu đi dạy thì chắc chắn rảnh anh ta
để sau đó như thế nào đấy
cái đấy không hứa lượng nhưng mà chất ra
tôi sẽ không bỏ kênh này rồi
nhưng mà tôi sẽ à
Ừ tôi sẽ dậy à
à hóa sau xa gần nhất cha Đà và sẽ dạy
theo phong cách kiểu dạng chuẩn bài bản
hơn lý thuyết thì chắc trả lời sẽ có
nhiều hơn nhưng mà biết đâu đấy Mình sẽ
dạy Cậu hay hơn thứ mình có kinh nghiệm
mà
à Còn việc lai thỉnh thoảng like cốt thì
có nhé Nói chung là vợ cái hướng cái
hướng của kênh của tôi về sau nó sẽ ở
như này đó là ít nhất là chắc chắn là
tôi vẫn sẽ phải để lại một cách Lady
Nhưng cái clip dạy cơ bản về tự ashwell
xong rồi web các thử thứ như tôi đang
làm nhưng mà sẽ là chuẩn chỉ hơn kiểu
bài bạn hơn theo phong cách của FPT rồi
ạ Chứ không còn là kiểu dạng là cái mấy
cái cái cũ này là theo phong cách tối
dậy ở trường cũ cái thứ hai là thỉnh
thoảng tôi vẫn sẽ có loại cốt đồng dạng
là chủ nhật chẳng chắc thế hôm nào lấy ở
chỗ là sẽ thông báo trước để mà kiểu tôi
sẽ livestream mình ngồi cốt một cái gì
đó từ đầu để cho mấy bạn xem hôm trước
của tôi vừa có ý tưởng hay phết mà tôi
sẽ làm một trang là Trang Nha Trang cá
nhân của tôi nó kiểu dạng là cái tên của
tôi tìm được lôi cả bạn show.com như ai
à khi nào sẽ vào sẽ hiển địa trang cá
nhân của tôi và trên đấy có kiểu nó
giống kiểu cev
kiểu trang blog điều cần thế bạn đương
nhiên sẽ bao gồm CV mình trên đấy toàn
bộ những cái thông tin mình muốn trên
đấy thôi Bởi vì a tôi xem lại cái trang
blog của tôi Thực ra nó hơi xấu Chẳng có
gì cả Chỉ Vlog như thế này và nó hơi bị
nhạt nhòa Tí và cái này dùng cái
template có sẵn ra tôi nhìn cái này tôi
cũng không hề hay lắm đấy tôi sẽ làm
thằng cá nhân mình mình làm đinh lăng
web mà mình nên có người trang cá nhân
không ạ
Anh
Khoa học Việt à nhà khoa học nhiệt đới
không Không biết cái nào rồi
là nhân mình mà mình thường xuyên cập
nhật lên đấy
Ừ cái trang giấy ở trong Block cơ bản
thôi mà đăng bài lên các thứ thứ đấy
tiếp theo của gì nhỉ À
thậm chí là tôi sẽ lại livestream để cốt
mình Cái phần mềm liên quan institute
này Trả lại tôi cảm thấy phải cái video
Bờ Tôi cần muốn chỉnh sửa nhanh lại cái
phần mô tả ấy để tôi làm cái một lúc
chẳng lạn cái tấn thứ thì đã bị lười quá
nên là xa tôi dùng phần mềm để nó tự
động Và thậm chí là có thể cho thuê phần
mềm mới hay gì không phải thuê nhưng mà
chúng mình cho chia sẻ phần mềm đấy cho
người khác bởi Chắc chắn là nhiều người
cũng muốn Ví dụ như về Ông có 100 cái
video thật dưới 1.000 cái video nhiều
hơn nhiều canh nhiều lắm Bây giờ tự như
ông muốn thêm một cái đường link và sóng
mọi cái mô tả của video làm nhà không
mua sửa ống tay á á
Em hãy vì thế ông làm phần mềm xong rồi
nó tự động thêm hộ ông đúng không méo
hiểu thì thôi ấy thì
Ừ thì mình là sẽ làm được những cái từ
đấy chú ạ
không ở công ty anh vẫn làm futech mà
Thì
về CS mà gần như là là
3G Swiff các thứ thứ
vùng dùng pin nhưng mà chủ yếu copy code
của những anh đi trước Dạ không làm rõ
về view lắm biết do speed thôi nhưng mà
Phi Uh nếu mà gần đây có vẻ biết hơn tí
rồi Mình đang học dân cải thiện dần hơn
rồi
nghĩ là nếu là người dùng thì sẽ như nào
anh lít - cho là mày bị thương sau tất
cả quá sẽ ra ai cũng thế mà hồi đầu thế
rồi đây kiểu Tôi làm phần mềm Tôi muốn
kiểu tôi bị tính cầu toàn Chắc là nhiều
người có thể bị dính cái điều đấy có
người thì bị cẩu thả không nói nếu mà
nhiều người bị cầu toàn thì lại suy nghĩ
phức tạp quá khiến cho kiểu bài toán đã
làm ví dụ làm phần mềm ấy chỉ trong một
tháng rồi mình làm thận mua thận bao
luôn thánh mà mình vẫn bù đắp đi làm lại
vì cảm thấy à Ừ hôm nay tự nhiên lại
thấy một cái Pocket nào nó hay mình mỗi
ô mơ về em những thứ nên thành ra là
mô hình thành gia là Kiều Hòa
đôi khi chúng ta nên đặt trước một cái
bếp like rồi chúng ta thực hiện các từ
thứ làm nên của mô hình thác nước thôi
chứ làm theo kiểu dạng là thỉnh thoảng
ngồi review lại có giữ thứ thì muốn đập
đi làm lại nhiều lắm và mình phải suy
nghĩ việc và mình làm nó nhiều phần mềm
hơn là làm một cái rồi cứ ngồi chị Lý
chừng lại một cái
Ừ nếu hiểu ạ Đấy nói chung và mấy ông cứ
phải trước mắt thì có một cái lại cầu
toàn làm đi làm lại cũng được
cái đấy là kiểu dạng giống Nhờ chăm chút
nó một tí giống như một cái con à Có đứa
con tinh thần nó gọn nhưng mà Ngoài ra
thì mình có thể làm rất nhiều cái phần
mềm Cậu Nho Nhỏ khác và mình làm để chia
sẻ trong cộng đồng các người thứ
Anh thường mà
xã hội
ở ga here Hồi trưa tôi từng nói là tôi
cũng dạy cho nhiều nhiều bạn học ở lớp
bổ túc thì có bạn cũng hiểu con lực vẫn
nhớ chính xác chị ấy buồn đấy thôi 22 23
tuổi gì đấy Dậy chị đấy à chế 30 chị tôi
kệ kia chị lấy kiểu bạn lái xe tải Không
học à Cũng không không điều hợp đại học
gì nhưng mà người làm nghề lái xe tải
thôi và đấy Lần đầu tiên bạn chị ấy cũng
sử dụng máy tính nữa chị chăm học chịu
khó
Ừ chị cũng học lập trình các hư học Quét
các bạn đấy à à
bia
em có một tí liên quan thôi thì K3 thì
bản chất là là nó cũng có tí tương đồng
là điểm là cũng phải hiểu người dùng cần
gì các thứ thứ để test các thứ thứ
Ừ anh nghĩa là được nhưng mà để mà hỏi
anh bia còn gì được ai không rõ lắm Anh
khá thích bia đấy be luôn Nếu mà làm
được tốt bè lương cao lắm
chị đã cả là kiểu Hòa nó hay nó có ra
Kiểu phân tích vậy mà mình không cần
phải à ấy mình không phải mua cút mấy
anh về sau mình nếu mà về sau tôi không
Khi mà không có được nữa thì thôi với
bắt đầu nhảy lên kiểu là bao lên 5 lít
Ừ chị Bé học sinh kể nhiều hôm nay không
ai bảo vệ thật à đúng đủ rồi Tôi đang ốm
cố kiểu của ON để mở cậu xem để chữa cho
mấy ông bảo vệ mà
chắc được cái gì cả tội vẫn không thấy
bảo là tôi không phải đã cấp thôi không
thể nào ngồi nói dối mày Ông là ai cũng
phù hợp với ngành cũng để không tin đâu
ạ Ai theo ngành này cũng theo được lương
Ngất Ngưởng không chịu đấy
nó chỉ nói thứ nhất là ai cũng nên học
lập trình để cho biết về tư duy này ạ và
và nó không khó cái học lập trình như cá
Xuống khó như Nhiều người nghĩ nếu bạn
để mà chuyên với nó thì thì đúng là khó
thật đâu dễ gì được 5 nghìn đô đâu đóng
ngoặc nhưng một khi mà các bạn mà hợp để
lương lên nghìn đô thì từ 1.000 đô lên
để chục nghìn đô rồi rất là dễ 100.000
đô không dám nói chưa Tôi không thể tôi
chưa đạt được đến mức đấy Nhưng bây giờ
tôi đang lương 1.000 đô á Tôi thích
nhưng mà đấy ở trên công ty tôi vì công
ty thôi sẽ lắp Còn nếu mà tôi nhảy sang
công ty khác thì thể lên 23 nghìn đô Và
thậm chí có thể lên hơn nữa
về chưa Bà
nghĩ em chỉ là khi mình để cái ngưỡng
sinh từ lúc đầu là kiểu chưa biết gì
được ạ thì ngồi học nên làm faso nó rất
là rẽ từ faster and Junior
à à lên hẳn Sino đi thì lại rất là khó
đấy ạ Nhưng mà khi lên sciglio rồi thì ở
cái dưỡng siro thì thì cái ngưỡng đấy
lương Mọi Thứ hai ra soạn bài Rap
Monster thì nó chỉ quá trình thời gian
tích lũy rồi Các bạn có tích lũy được
bao nhiêu bao nhiêu nữa thì nó sẽ lên
dần bị Master thế thôi
à à
anh có ý tưởng gì design web
anh đấy đấy thì vừa nãy tôi vừa nói là
tôi định làm trang web cá nhân đấy thì
các bạn sẽ biết cái khái niệm My stone
của hai tôi đang bị làm thế mai stone và
kiểu đó là những cột mốc trong cuộc đời
ấy ý
nhiều cư méo nên ăn cắp ý tưởng đâu nhá
kiểu ra cả là thức ạ kiểu gì chẳng tôi
tham khảo nhiều người thế rồi nhưng đại
khái thế kiểu dạ mà kéo xuống dần dần sẽ
kiểu lượng nó sẽ kiểu hình động đấy Nó
sẽ hiển thị Xa Dần dần dần là kéo tiểu
sử từ năm bao nhiêu mà nằm bao nhiêu đã
làm gì quần mốt như thế nào ấy thì ra có
nhiều trạm có rồi tôi cũng tham khảo
người khác luôn nói tôi không Nhớ thằng
nào lắm với lại khái nó kiểu thế
thêm đây để mà lỗ chia sẻ chia sẻ đốt
nếu béo để kỹ là cái trăm lít hát của
tôi Như ạ Nó cứ mỗi lần mà chẳng ghi học
của tôi có dùng để aaaa à
anh em em miễn phí
ở đây mà có chết rồi đây ở đây không đấy
thì kết hợp với dùng thocan ở trên
spotify tôi để luôn hiển thị là bài Tôi
đang nghe hiện tại chính xác và bài cuối
rồi tao nghe chính xác như thế chỉ ở đây
này sang cây khác cười quá thì cái này
tôi sẽ làm cho trang web của tôi cũng có
cái như này Đấy cái tôi sẽ ôm hết về để
cậu rảnh là tôi sẽ chia sẻ rất nhiều cái
tun và tôi từng chia sẻ rất nhiều mạng
xã hội tôi của tôi chứ nhân Chắc chắn
rồi và kèm theo cả bài Tôi đang nghe các
thứ tự fortify ở trên đấy nữa Chẳng ạ
Đây ạ
[âm nhạc]
nói chung là kiểu đấy ra trang cá nhân
của ông và định nghĩa nó Nó là kiểu thế
giới thiệu bạn đã gian ông nóng bọn nó
không cần phải như một cái CV nhưng mà
bây giờ cứ Hình dung là Kẹo bé gấu đi
tán gái ông muốn cái cha của ông này đem
đi tán gái như thế nào để nó cân phải có
tí màu mẹ có và thể hiện rõ ông Dân công
nghệ đúng ạ Đấy các thứ Nếu mà cũng
không nên cậu Hòa
Ông Lênin à nếu mà bị dài dòng quá thì
vợ không lên đúng ạ nói chung mà kiểu gì
Nói chung là mỗi ông có cái trình béo
thể tham khảo về nước ngoài ra có nhiều
mà
em dựa vào gì ở đánh giá yunio Singapore
Hình như là tội tưởng nó một đoạn đấy Ở
một cái video cũ của tôi rồi à
hot girl Chính đây đây đây thêm một cái
nữa đó là vừa rồi Tôi nói là tôi sẽ làm
cái phần mềm để mà kiểu làm để mà phải
việc cập nhật mô tả của những cái á
những cái video cũ tôi không ạ Tôi sẽ
làm phần mềm đấy để làm gì thì cứ ngồi
xem lại những ngày toàn bộ cơ thể review
lại toàn bộ những cái video của tôi từng
đăng nhá Tôi tôi Đánh Dấu Mục lục và tôi
lưu lại cái mục lục đấy ở trên cái trang
nào đó là sử thậm chí về sau trên trang
cá nhân tôi ở mục lục Tôi đã từng dậy
đấy Xong rồi định nghĩa tôi là tôi nói
qua những cái gì phải bạn Thế ở hết chứ
Trang đấy để phía sau miệng để về sau
Giả sử có một ông nào hỏi tôi mình câu 1
tuổi tự trả lời rồi tôi gửi cho ông ấy
danh sách đấy thôi ông chỉ cần Cha Cha
chứ Trang đấy em ạ Ừ rồi bấm Ảo thì nó
sẽ nó mà Đức Linh ở nó sẽ nhảy lên cái á
đoạn video YouTube đến đúng cái đoạn dây
thứ bao nhiêu lấy để mà ngồi nghe cái
kiểu như thế
anh méo hiểu ý tưởng ông ạ Cái kiểu đấy
nhất là phần mềm này vừa hỗ trợ việc là
chỉnh sửa mô tả bản chất là chỉnh sửa mô
tả cũng sẽ hỗ trợ mình chỉnh sửa các mục
lục bởi vì a mục lục của visa thường
chiếc là phải đi cho mượn mô tả nhé Đấy
Hiện tôi sẽ làm mục lục đấy và tôi sẽ
làm cha tổng hợp tất cả mục lúc đấy của
tất cả video ở một trang nào đó nữa đấy
sau đó đi thi mà ai hỏi gì tôi tôi chỉ
được có thể họ không biết từ khóa để tra
thì tôi sẽ lên chính Trang là nhân tôi
coi tra rồi tôi tôi copy cái link tớ gửi
họ Thế là xong lẽ mình đỡ sợ mày nói lại
nữa
anh Bởi vì sao Bởi vì ở thực tế hả tăng
ca tôi hơi bị ngại nói lại ở điểm là vì
mỗi lần mình nói lại khi móng kể đi kể
lại một câu nào đó nó sẽ không còn giống
như ban đầu ông nói chắc chắn rồi có thể
nó sẽ thêm pháp đổi ý gì đó và nó sẽ bớt
đi một tí gì đó nữa
em liên lạc được cả Tôi không thích nói
lại một cái gì đó
hãy thay đổi góc nhìn đi Tôi đánh giá
lại một cái thì cho tôi nói được Giờ sự
là cư Cái gì chọn ví dụ vài ngày thôi
trả lời lại một câu ấy thì nó sẽ không
còn trọn vẹn được như ban đầu thì nó lại
mất hay nghĩ là thế
thì ông mới này được nói chứ nháy biết
kệ không phải thông tin rồi chúng nó sẽ
bảo dịch tra này toàn HTML à
tiền thuê server ông ông dùng Thậm chí
bây giờ ghi pháp mà miễn phí rồi ông
dùng nên ông Dũng mà đi toppic của thằng
Nhí hấp được mà Nhưng mà ông cần thấy
mắc em nữa hay các từ thư nữa thì tôi đã
hosting miễn phí rồi có mà chắc là nhân
không có phải lượng truy cập vào cao đâu
mà không sợ bị quá tải gì đó để cái
thằng miễn phí nó rẻ không và nó đủ dùng
ờ ờ
cho mình hình ơi mình từng dùng Line up
để mà học cách để mà học à ch và mình
quên hết rồi nên là mình không dậy các
bạn với vụ này được
Ừ nhưng mình đang cân nhắc nhở cấp nhất
là mình sẽ phải sử dụng thêm một vài hệ
điều hành và thể like nhất thậm chí mát
thì mà mình à
như là
nhiều cái mình kia mình dùng thêm những
cái công nghệ mới thì mình sẽ mình bắt
đầu sẽ có sự so sánh giữa cài mình đang
dùng với cái trước đó ngọn thì mình sẽ
thấy những điểm nào hay những điểm đó
giờ không thử bìa dân công nghệ mình
mình rất thịnh mò thêm những cái mới dồi
thế tôi rất thích mò luôn khi mà sang
bất kỳ cái á có phần mềm nào tôi thường
hay ăn vào phần setting cái giá mua điện
thoại mới về tổn thương ơi cậu chỉ ngồi
mò hai tiếng 23 tiếng đồng hồ thì ngồi
Vào setting để ngồi trình chính trị và
xem là cái này có những cái gì mới thì
hai cái thứ thứ lỗi thường ai xem kiểu
nó cái chi tiết bản cập nhật Noel even
nữa hãy từ hồi chưa phải ở dân công nghệ
nhé Vợ thích mò một cái đấy rồi
Ừ anh có bao giờ sử dụng email z à à
công nghệ gì đó thôi AK này
Ừ ừ béo có bảo vệ thật là Alo hôm trước
mấy chỉ có 14 thành 5 nhóm bảo vệ mà
những bốn nhóm những nhóm còn lại mất
tích đâu hết rồi
ừ ừ
có người nào Hôm nay thứ ba thì có thể
nhiều với bận nếu mà nói chung gồm mấy
ông không bảo vệ Hôm nay thì cũng được
không xa thì thì tôi bảo đấy thì những
buổi hôm sau thì mày ông hoàn toàn thể
chủ động bảo là bảo vệ thử nhé con Nếu
mà nói chung là tôi vẫn muốn là kiểu mì
ông nha
anh em nay bảo vệ sớm về đi Ví dụ tôi
vẫn đang chốt mà hiện tại trước mắt nữa
là sẽ mùng 10 tháng 9 ở chùa à hôm à
Anh à
hôm 17 phải đi lấy 7 này thì méo nghỉ lễ
nghỉ rồi nếu thế hôm thử
nụ hôn từ 6 nhập Đúng một tuần nữa đi
mùng 6 thì tôi sẽ thôi kiểm tra xem cốt
của méo này đâu đấy Xong rồi à
Ừ mùng 5 mùng thứ năm tuần sau thì tôi
bắt đầu một kiểm tra tài liệu gồm với
ông đấy đâu rồi để mà Hùng 10 như tôi đã
bảo thì sẽ có khách mời tao thử thứ để
mà tham dự thì tôi tôi muốn là nói chung
là kiểu gì cũng phải diệt qua về các bạn
mấy ông vẫn là gọi là đại diện để mà
hiểu mình đại diện cho chính cao và đại
diện nó việc tôi đã dạy như nào đưa tao
phải diệt thôi không ạ Có thể kiểu
em gửi kẹo rồi sao lên bảo vệ được sẽ
thật rồi à à
Trung Thu chú đủ tế thiếu nhi Tết được
mấy ông đâu thế thử nhi cũng là Tết của
mình cái đứa có gấu thì có bảo gì có
ở ngôi nhà thôi
à à
[âm nhạc]
nói chung là cẩu chuẩn bị rất cả những
cái gì
thực ra là Tôi chỉ nghĩ là bảo vệ kiểu
trước mắt Có thể những ngón có thể bốn
nhóm Hôm trước cũng được những người
nhóm tiêu biểu trước Nếu mà nhỏ mà tự
tin hơn với bảo vệ trước cũng được không
xa để mà kiểu con đến Đông nhóm hơn thì
cũng không sao cả chưa Có vài nhóm kiểu
tặng là hôm đấy ổn
từ trước để lệ làm gọi là
vợ nghỉ làm gương mà các thứ trước
à à
Ừ hình như là đã nói gì hôm đấy sẽ có cả
Hấp rồi nên thấy ra mấy ông hôm đấy mà
càng ổn thì alo có thể tuyển được luôn
càng tốt cho mấy ông nữa bạn đấy và
gương mặt đó tôi thì nó cũng một phần
tôi cũng là cũng vui Cũng vui khi mà
thấy sinh viên bảo vệ 20 chú ạ
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
bản chất là các bạn cứ Các bạn cứ làm
xong rồi bảo bảo mình để mà mình chấm
nhau thôi chứ còn mà
Ừ chứ còn đợt đoán mới như mình bảo là
bây giờ mình sẽ định là sẽ có khóa sau
Nhưng mà mình không chắc chắn được là
khóa sau sẽ bao giờ như là nói chung là
bạn nào cứ học đến đâu xong muốn làm đồ
án thì cứ làm xong rồi bảo mình sẽ chữa
qua thôi thì inbox riêng của mình để
mình chuyển qua thế được
à Còn buổi bảo vệ và khóa sau thì chắc
bảo vệ kiểu hành chính thức ra từ thứ
chắc phải được khóa sau rồi
i-mobile các bạn đã bị lẻ quá thì không
không không tổ chức được Kiểu gì đó
ở những cảnh này thời gian cái ngày tôi
thế hơi bị dở Quang điểm là chứ Giờ
không có full ha mày parttime ở đây cả
phát ra mà như là bởi vì mình có làm
hiểu rõ đủ giờ chẳng lẽ là ông đang cốt
để kiểu đủ 4 giờ ông nhỉ À không phải
như thế ông Gửi ông ấy xong việc giờ mới
nghỉ và xong việc ở đây Khanh thì full
Ham đâu đấy là cái parte anh thấy nó bị
Hơi đưa tôi nghĩa đương nhiên là có công
ty nó vẫn có khái niệm đấy nhưng mà theo
ý tôi thì là parttime là gần như nó đang
nói thẳng là nó trừ lương của ông có thể
Ông làm vẫn đủ nhưng thằng Fullham Nhưng
mà nó cũng tính không được bạn sao thế
này ra là ông phải nói là có công ty là
cho ông làm remote lại không hiểu thế và
không cần để làm giờ hành chính là được
nghĩa Vì nhà mình ở đâu còn hằn phải lên
công ty hay làm rồi mình đâu ông Nghĩa
là nói chung nó ra việc của ông Xong rồi
ông làm được à Cậu tình yêu đương nhiên
có thể chậm hơn những người khác như
cũng là Phantom mà Đấy ông hiểu do con
Part 20 phút hàm ra đây không có trạm
làm đâu
chứ không phải làm kiểu không phải lên
công ty đủ 4 miếng mỗi ngày đâu mà bắt
hạp
chung không cứ làm quét cơ bản sau đó
thì ông nhờ rồi chấm qua này thì cái
lệnh Quét các bạn không thể làm mình nhớ
con Web nâng cao này thì một là ông
thích làm cái còn theo nhóm bị đội hại
nhưng mà đợi thì không biết bao giờ vì
đội thì tôi dạy khóa sau tôi sẽ dạy bao
lâu thì các bạn cơ
nghĩa là sẽ phải mất nửa năm ý nhất là
như thế để mà 10 đến khóa nâng cao
ở đây là ông đợi khóa sau rất là lâu
đúng ạ việc là
không lấy người năm thì mỗi đợi một
người mà chưa chắc là kiểu người sẽ như
nào thì tôi nghĩ đâu cứ làm một hai cái
trước đi
lại người tâm sửa em mà ông muốn nói cái
gì hay muốn hỏi gì cứ hỏi lại bây giờ
lại chuẩn bị tâm sự tuổi học rồi à
Ế là là kiểu à
anh
tự đánh giá bản thân mình là hồi trước
mình dậy thì có thể chưa đủ vài bạn chưa
đủ kiến thức kiến thức ở đây về mặt lý
thuyết đấy
Ừ thì tôi đang muốn là sẽ dạy lại hàm
một cái khóa chuẩn theo kiểu phong cách
của bên
không chưa trình ở bên FPT đề mà tôi dạy
khóa sau nghĩa tôi dậy lại cơ bạc từ đầu
luôn bởi vì có những video tôi xem lại
thì đúng là có nhiều cái có thể bạn đấy
Mình thể dạy ổn hơn nhưng mà bây giờ
chẳng lẽ mình xóa video đi Nói chung là
tôi định là nói chung một mẹ nếu mà phía
sau có thời gian sẽ dạy lại hành khóa
mới tha thứ mọi thứ đều trở thành thứ
ờ ờ
dạng là
avi cái hồi mà mình làm avi thì mình
dùng api của support của Facebook lẫn cả
là làm mấy cái Facebook nhiều thì mình
có vẻ hiểu được hơn à
hai tay để mình sẽ trả lời những câu
khác người rồi để mô aki bạn nhé bây giờ
bắt đầu học có kịp không
Bạn có học thôi toàn bộ video mình có
hết ở trên trên kênh của mình rồi thì
bạn là nó sẽ tried ít nhá
anh phi thương bất hủ
ô nhiễm đất Cố Đô là gì
quen quen
anh không giàu có
doanh buôn bán
bất hủ là không dầu có tài lộc viên hơn
bất phú là không kinh doanh thì không
giàu kiểu như thế đúng không
cái này thì thực ra là nó đúng vừa sai
về ATI nhá Ờ
thì tại sao là đúng Tại sao sai à
Ừ đúng là điểm là theo quan điểm với
trước của tôi nghĩ thì thực ra là để làm
giàu theo kiểu là ví dụ Giả sử béo không
có gì tay đúng không Ông muốn trong một
kiếp này của ông có thể giàu lên nữa
ngon Làm thế nào để giàu nhanh thế là
cậu ông phải làm những cái thứ nó hơi bị
ạ chắc chắn phải khác người mới giàu
nhanh được nó phải có một ăn nhiều nó
mới giàu nhanh được Heaven - ông ngồi
Teco thì đứa nào học tích góp các thử
đưa tiết kiệm đã thử rất khó để dầu kiểu
gì ông phải liên quan để mình kinh doanh
đầu tư có sự Xứ
đúng không nói à
Ừ thì
kinh doanh ở đây kinh doanh rất xám thì
cũng đúng Nhưng em rất sáng ở đây không
có thể cậu không phải là kiểu ông đi làm
thuê mà ấm chị ông sẽ làm nó phần mềm
ông cho thuê họ thêm ông thường và cho
thuê hoặc gạo đem bán gì đó Đây là mô
hình thức kinh doanh không ạ
nhưng mà ý tôi là
Ừ để mà giàu
doanh những cái điều đấy Ông vẫn thể chỉ
làm thuê Ông vẫn giàu được theo kiểu là
ông có tố chất sau đó thì ông lên nữa
Nhấn vị trí vào đó thì lương của ông về
sau lương của ông ổn định và kết hợp
được cả ông lên làm lít về sau thì ông
cũng khá là nhàn nhàn Bởi vì ông không
còn lại ngồi ạ đấu tranh đã thử làm nữa
ông không ngồi cày nữa thì ông vẫn có
tiền mà cái nhàng không phải mỗi ngành
này mà nhiều ngành khác
khi đôi khi ông lên làm cái trước đó thì
ông cũng có tiền ở đó đủ nên tôi Nghĩa
không cần nhất thiết phải à
kinh doanh để giàu nhưng mà Đúng là nếu
Ừ nếu mà ông muốn giàu nhanh thì chắc
chắn là phải con kinh doanh thật
cho tôi thì tôi nghĩ à Tôi không kinh
doanh nhưng về sau à theo nhiều nghề
Nhiều thầy bói hay ai đó bảo tôi ở phía
sau từ kiểu gì Vì sao tôi sẽ giàu Kỳ à
Tôi không muốn đều cả là tôi không không
có ý định rằng cậu
em kinh doanh các biểu tượng về sau kiểu
gì rồi sẽ giàu cha là kiểu nghĩa đến gỡ
của đó ông gọi là họ chạn bát trả lại
ông cái gì đó xứng đáng với năng lực của
ông thì kiểu gì ông rằng gọi có tí tiền
thì kiểu thế
cô dâu ở đây đội nhưng mà tôi không gọi
không hướng đến là giàu đâu Kiểu là cực
kỳ giàu hay gì đó mà tôi lắm chị đã đủ
đủ sống thôi
được phải lên mạng search thì mới làm
được thì có theo ngành được không
Ừ ừ cái điều này nó hơi bị sai đó là
kiểu ngày ngày bắt buộc phải lên tranh
và đọc tài liệu nhiều kể cả sao dù ngày
nào ấy phải chạy đi Sao lại rồi đấy thì
cũng không sao Bà nói chung là kỹ năng
trai của em
Ừ nó cải thiện được hàng ngày và ông nhớ
được từ khóa thôi chứ có rất nhiều cái
ngày nào anh chạy đi ạ Bởi vì các bạn
não mình không cần nhớ tất cả những điều
đấy để không phải xạo nên không sao về
vấn đề đấy à
Ừ Cái quan trọng là em không nhớ được từ
khóa và em lười đọc tài liệu tiếng Anh
rất thứ thứ khi nó mới mới là thứ khó em
phải không lưỡi em hãy kiên trì có thể
thứ thì hoa lần ổn định theo ngày nay
sẽ là mấy biện sẽ cái mô của api à
à à
thôi Nó kiểu bẩn chất ỉa hả
ý nghĩa là ông
kệ đi Ai nó là gì đây
à à
khái Nó kiểu như này Nó kiểu nó là kiểu
nó liên quan đến an tâm bây và giả sử
đây là cái
ở cục server của ông cụ máy chủ của ông
thi
anh không thấy ở đây có rất nhiều trường
diện này rất nhiều hệ điều hành mà nói
ngọng rất nhiều hệ điều hành rất nhiều
trình duyệt sử dụng là người dùng có thể
dùng kéo map người dùng Android điện
thoại người dùng Windows hoặc và có thể
dùng nhiều chính giữa khác nhau nghe gọi
đến cùng uống server của ong để lấy
thông tin về nó bạn ví dụ Ông bà trang
cá nhân của một ai đó thì nó sẽ trả về
ảnh đại diện của họ và toàn bộ bài đăng
Họ đang ở nặng thì toàn bộ những người
đấy có phải trả về trả về
anh béo thẻ giao diện ở trên mát Nó diện
ở trên điện thoại hãy giang chuyện trên
Windows hay ở trên nhiều thì giờ nó sẽ
phải khác khác nhau một tí để phù hợp
với cái á hệ điều hành đấy hay ở với cái
chưa đấy Đúng vậy nhưng mà giữ trả về
thì lại phải nên thống nhất nên thống
nhất cùng một kiểu Bởi vì bởi vì kiểu nó
mà khác kiểu thì vợ mỗi thằng này nó học
với một kiểu khác nhau là không đọc được
nó nên thống nhất có một điều Thì đấy
khái niệm về anh với ai nó chỉ đơn giản
thế thôi làm cái gì à khi mà gọi đến thì
nó sẽ trả lời gì đó có thể trả về hoặc
là chỉ làm thì nó đẩy lên thì mình nên
nó lại thì cái toàn bộ khái niệm này gọi
api thức à Thằng trung gian bọn nó là
cái gì kìa Nó là một cái Phương giúp cho
nó khóa
Chị chuẩn hóa việc là mình tương tác với
dữ liệu giữa giữa Tottenham và những và
dự tao bay và những cái thằng kiểu dạng
là thằng vial cái thứ thứ
nếu bà Kiểu
Khi dịch bắt bổ nó sẽ thế
Ở
đây bây giờ thử ví dụ nó sẽ như là
bây giờ gọi đến cái đường link đó nó sẽ
thảm phải dữ liệu của người dùng để nạn
đúng ạ ạ
ý là user này rồi gạch chéo nhé Rồi ai
đi như này thì mình sẽ còn đến hầm thôi
gọi hầm sâu thế này để lấy toàn bộ dữ
liệu người dùng về kiểu như này ạ ạ
Dù sau này trưa nay đi lên như này sau
đó thì mình mặc định thằng nào đeo nó đã
hỗ trợ là kiểu khi mình trả về
anh như này rồi thì nó sẽ tự động
Converse mình ra dạ reason Tức là nó dữ
liệu à
ừ
về dữ liệu thì nó sẽ có hai cái chuẩn và
bây giờ đang dùng một là kiểu reason 2
áo kiểu oa xml đây vẫn đúng không vào
đấy phải giờ đúng rồi nghỉ à
Ừ anh như nhảy ở tháng 9 này
đổi nhiều rồi
à à
ừ ừ
3:00
bây giờ của tôi là
Ừ mình đang dùng nào tới bây gì nhỉ
à à are you school
are you school này
Có ai đi to như này mà sao không bảo
được à
Ừ đấy thì mày Ông thấy em nó trả về
thằng nào em đã hỗ trợ mặc định khi
Return như thế này trở về dữ liệu họ trả
về thời đoạn reason Nếu mà tôi xem do
nhưng mình cũng sẽ thấy phải trả bây giờ
thí sinh nhưng ai như tôi dùng ngày thư
viện
reason Woa này nó sẽ trả về cổng ngay
cái kiểu như này Thế là sao Là bây giờ
nếu mà khi mà chả dữ liệu về như này thì
bên giao diện thì nó muốn ít nữa kiểu gì
phải in dụng Avatar này nó không in ra
cả đường linh như này họ sẽ kiểu biến
hình một cái ảnh đấy email nó sẽ in ra
kiểu như nào đấy Thì đấy là việc của
quan để xử lý còn khi dữ liệu trả về thì
mình nên trả về dữ liệu dạng nó chuẩn
hóa là Duy Xuân hoa cà xml như là bây
giờ phổ biến nhất dân đến con chỉ nói
với sân nội sinh rất là sao thí sinh tất
cả một cái đối tượng này như thế này và
nó sẽ trả về theo kiểu là nó
Ừ nó nếu mà các bạn để ý Sơn Đấy nó sẽ
là kiểu thứ nhất đó là kỳ của nó sẽ làm
trong chuỗi như kiểu một là chuỗi hay là
cửa số và số thì nó sẽ hiểu số thì nó sẽ
không nằm chỗ ở ngay Nếu để ý kĩ kiểu dữ
liệu như nó sẽ có chỗ ở đây nha ngoại số
này Đấy xong rồi kể cái này là do thằng
ngày nó trả về như thế này nhá
anh nói chung là các bạn thì được không
cần phải lo lắng về việc à là nó sẽ trả
về như nào vì thằng lao hỗ trợ mặc định
nó sẽ con với từ kể cả Android lẫn thành
Vision nữa các bạn rồi nhưng mà các bạn
dùng meet ơn nha có mình quan tâm đến
việc à Ừ gọi nên api kiểu như này truyền
ID lên thì nó trả về dữ liệu của bạn
thêm ngoài ra thêm thì còn cái gì nữa
thì thậm chí là không truyền ai đi lên
mình chả phải toàn bộ tất cả u dơ thì
sao hạ thế
à à
ạ bây giờ sự không truyền ai đi lên như
thế này vào uzair ngay thôi
Em tắt hết toàn bộ công an nhé thì nó sẽ
trả về thường gọi đến Hà mà Hà Min đấy
Ừ nó trả về toàn bộ giờ như nào ạ
Em đang ở nhà cháu ạ
à à
mạnh chứa các đối tượng mà nó cũng sẽ
dạng mỗi đối tượng là một
Nó là âm Trách di dân các thứ thôi đấy
đúng điệu như này Ok chị ạ
ở đây cũng là một api hại là một ivi tất
cả nó sẽ trả về dạng di dân hết cho các
bạn vào thấp ngoài ra nó sẽ còn thế nào
nữa
ngoài ra giả sử là
ờ ờ Các bạn thấy cái mối quan hệ vừa rồi
Ở đây không phải là gọi lên rồi trả về
mà nó sẽ bao gồm đẩy thông pin lên và nó
sẽ xử lý là lưu lại dữ liệu và nó có thể
thường nó sẽ trả về kết quả thành công
nên thất bại được như mọi khi tôi làm và
Return ngày trên này thành công hay thất
bại ạ
Ừ thì giả sốt 7 thông tin lên mà nó trả
về thành công hay thất bại theo tôi thì
ví dụ ví dụ thậm chí ở như thế này
Chúng tôi có một cái Script nhà tôi sẽ
ghi tên một cái view all
khi cài protect đ
anh ở đây có rồi eklendi
the floor ngay
cho mình điểm nên nó này
khi hút hay là
nem này
khi đăng nhập cách chứ Nên mà Nam trước
một tuần là Ok em ạ về đi rồi sẽ chuẩn
nhớ đến hả
thì mình sẽ nhảy đến
Ừ cái Crack này à
có một cái là lưu lại
bình thường là nó sẽ là
gà đều dơ crash uzair gỗ stress
A và đây sẽ là u dơ thôi mà để sẽ lắp
Porsche
mệt hết này là Porsche
hôm nay sẽ ăn lên nó là to lưu lại này
ở đây
ở địa điểm router là store lưu lại hớp
là post
Chevrolet à
ừ ừ
à à
khi
đôi khi ở gọi như này thì ông sẽ phải
gọi nó trước cái thằng này để cho nó
không bị hỏng ghi đè lên thì ông mới gọi
được nếu ngay ok rồi thật sự là ở xem là
cái này bắt buộc phải điện cái gì đã nên
mẹ chóng email gọi điện
Ừ Ok Thế mũi email bắt buộc phải điện
thôi tôi đổi Email nhé á
à à
anh nghe nhạc điền vào một cái như này
các bạn hình ảnh class nhà
thế này
à à
nhà là u rô này crash này đi quét lại
toàn bộ những cái mình chuyên Lê này nếu
thành công thì mình sẽ Return một cái
sắp xít như ai
chẳng hạn thế à
ai chả thế nhá
Đây vsport hiểu về thí sinh nhá trở về
nó phê phê ạ Cái gì đó chạy thử này xe
tải thành công nóng ạ thêm nếu bây giờ
giả sử là chạy phát nữa nha à
thì nó sẽ phone bởi vì sao Bởi vì Ozil
này đã tạo rồi mình không được phép lặp
lại cái á email này nữa là sẽ trả phone
thậm chí nếu không thấy em vừa rồi là
tôi phải mất cong điền vào trong cái
phom như thế này thì nó mới chạy đến đến
cái đêm cái ếch cho đến ngày em Point là
bọn post user không ạ Tôi không cần phải
làm thế có thể dùng Batman để làm điều
đấy nó sẽ thử làm nhé là mấy ông này
Chúng tôi sẽ đợi mệt hết này mới thức
post này xong rồi chuyền vào cái form ở
đây thôi đây sẽ lại email này
ở đây sẽ là ABC nghe trở lại ẩn đẩy lên
nè
đến 419 tất cả bởi vì tôi không trường
cfz lên đây thường là
để cho bảo mật thì thằng Alan nó thêm sẽ
vừa ép để kiểm tra đúng ạ thì giả sử tôi
tạm tắt nó đi nhé vì tôi đang không có
lây truyền nên tôi tạm giác là đi nữa
nhé á
I said Yes lâu vậy
ừ ừ
không cần phải vào hẳn cả một cái com để
mà điền thông tin nóng ạ không cần lò xo
mài niềm tin tôi thể truyền lên từ ở bất
kỳ đâu miễn là tôi gọi được đúng nên cái
port này nói chuyện đủ thông tin là có
nhiều nó trả về cho mình là thành công
rồi đấy nó trả về giá 200 thành công và
trở về mình đã di dân như thế này tuy
nhiên gọi thêm lần nữa nó sẽ biến thành
fo Vì sao Vì email tồn tại rồi thì đây
cũng được tính có một api apr này là
iPad để đẩy thông tin lên đấy apr này để
api này để nhận thông tin về các bạn đấy
api cho chị Thực ra nó chỉ đơn giản
quanh quẩn lại đôi nghĩa đầy đủ tính can
xem thêm sửa xóa của ông nó sẽ gọi đến
một cái em quay một cái đường dẫn này
thì một là nó trả về thông tin cho ông
mấy ông hay là ông ông kiểu ông đầy
thông tin lên cho nó để nó lưu lại trong
ra đây và thông báo cho ông về thành
công ấy thất bạn Ừ thế thôi Thứ nhất api
luôn trả về là dạng Vissan hoa cả xml
nhưng mà bây giờ sẽ sân thì béo chuyển
nhờ listener đôi thứ hai ý là đấy mẹ ông
thấy là đôi khi để truyền cho chuẩn đấy
không phải truyền thêm cả mấy cái tóc em
mấy cái gì đó để mà kiểm tra quyền của
ông để ông truy cập và FBI đấy khi uống
đủ quyền hay gì đó thì ông được phép vào
để đẩy thông tin vào lưu lại trong
lazabay thẩm mỹ này đấy thế thôi
ý nghĩa là nếu mà giả sử là đây là giao
diện web của tôi ở như thế này nhưng mà
rõ ràng là ở trên cái điện thoại giao
diện của tôi nó sẽ khác ở trên ở trên
cậu trình duyệt nhiều trình duyệt giao
diện nó sẽ khác nhưng chung quy nó vẫn ở
gọi đến đường dẫn này vẫn truyền đầy đủ
thông tin như này đúng không ạ đẩy lên
cái đồ dẫn này thì cái đường dẫn này nó
gọi là một este cái kiểu như thế thôi
nào mà
Ừ ông nào mà Thanh Thảo hơn về cách
giảng có thể giản qua tội cho các bạn
đấy hộ tôi Tôi cũng không biết làm thế
nào cho nó nghe nó nó dễ hiểu hơn ở chỗ
lại tôi chỉ khẳng định api tôi làm việc
với nó rất rất nhiều rồi nhưng
Ừ Để mà giải thích nó một cách dễ hiểu
được cả hơi khó vì về cơ bản thì em biết
ai nhiều người cứ nghĩ nó bị phức tạp
được ra nó khá là đơn giản mình làm vì
cái nó suốt rồi đấy vẫn chỉ làm đầy đủ
tính năng xem thêm sửa xóa bình thường
nó cũng tính là một ivi rồi Chỉ có duy
nhất cái cái class này cái thì chị cho
giao diện như này
lịch thi đấu mà bia thôi Bởi vì nó chạm
với giao diện còn toàn bộ những cái
thằng nào mà cháu về dạng reason Cá thứ
nó cũng thể được tính của api vì ông
truyền lên dữ liệu và ông trả về dinh
dưỡng cho nó là một like con uống trà về
dạng HT lời như này cũng trả về một cái
gì đó thì nó không được tính gây ra thế
thôi theo dễ hiểu không có trả cái sân
này nó của apa đấy ạ
Ừ Ok nghỉ còn bạn nào thắc mắc gì nữa
càng ngày càng tăng lên
mới trở đi tôi vẫn vẫn chưa thi một lần
hai cái phone lần nào nghe hack các con
thú vị hết Cái cái hôi mà tôi tôi được
nghe về HK con nhiều lắm cậu nhiều người
bảo đi cứ Tôi cứ tưởng khách các con rồi
nên mình hack ạ tôi của mình nghĩa tình
của dân lập trình mình biết gì về hack
cái mình là mình không đi xong về Sao
lại biết 2k con này nó bạn chất là do
trẻ lập trình em sự thứ chẳng qua kéo
theo để làm nhanh một cái sản phẩm vào
đó cái thật tôi có nhiều ý tưởng ăn thì
à Tôi nghĩ là tôi đi rồi đấy Cái gì tôi
cũng được giải với ý tưởng
à à
Ừ tôi không nói là sắp tôi có thành công
hay tôi làm được không nha Tôi chỉ nói
tôi có những ý tưởng thôi
là lỗi mà kỷ niệm mình thực tế mình vẫn
còn đây ít
Ừ nếu đường Thi Sách hai hạt cát họ lại
công nhận nó sẽ khó hơn so với các bạn
sinh viên trẻ người các sữa xứ
ở đâu ở già rồi thì sẽ không ngồi cái
đêm để ngồi làm không được nữa Chả thế
thêm gì thì chắc à Bố mày kết thúc đây à
Nếu không có tâm sự hoài đáp gì nữa
không
Ê mày không có cái gì như vậy đâu
cho anh bao nhiêu tuổi À mình sinh năm
Anh bao giờ cưới ạ
Ừ ừ
dự định của tôi sẽ là 529 theo lời thầy
bói Bà bói à
à Còn hiện tại thì nhưng mà đấy là kiểu
ạ khi tôi nghĩa là tôi cầm có thêm thời
gian để mà hoàn thiện bản thân về chiến
thắng thứ việc ở
định chứ bây giờ mà mình là mình kiểu
mình còn nhiều cái dự định còn chưa làm
mà cứ hư
vấn gần đây của tôi ở bên FA thì người
ta cũng chị hỏi tôi kéo đại khái là kiểu
đã dậy những cái gì xong rồi bảo tôi gửi
cho họ cái chương trình đào tạo tôi thử
tự sản cái xem như nào thì tôi đi dạy mà
à
Vì sao tôi theo tuổi tác với nói chung
và phỏng vấn từ trước này tôi vẫn về các
bạn thì nó khá dễ vì gần như à đều được
mời về hơn nên là gần như là chị nói hỏi
qua kiểu quá học qua xem tôi từng làm
cái gì cái việc là ngồi nói với giới
thiệu quay mức lương tôi cũng không lưu
lương bao giờ nên thì gà cũng không biết
chia sẻ nếu kinh nghiệm về gì mấy
khi
quan hệ giữa phố đắp và codocla á á
thế
này thì ỉa
Tí Chắc là hỏi riêng thì tôi chỉ kỹ hơn
cho bạn ra thế kỷ hơn là bạn được
tác thì nó có ảnh hưởng nhiều cái hấp
Ừ nhưng mà ờ
anh nói chung à Tôi nghĩa là chưa bao
giờ làm quá muộn để mà mình một thay đổi
một cái gì đó cả mình vẫn còn kiểu Minh
Minh vẫn còn có thể thì mình vẫn
Ừ mình vẫn đi làm chứ không phải là cẩu
cỡ thấy à Thôi bây giờ kiểu nhiều người
bên ngoài thành công có thứ để đưa mình
chưa làm gì cả thì
Khi mình suy nghĩ thế
khi đôi khi làm nạn chết ông ông không
so sánh bản thân mình với bất kỳ ai cả
tôi người nói hết rồi không so sánh mình
với quá khứ nghĩa là bây giờ có thể ông
đang giận thương lại chỗ so với quá khứ
thật họa thì ông chỉ cần cố tiến lên
thôi Ông cảm thấy có vấn đề tiến lên các
thứ thứ đúng là mình nhìn những người
khác có thể đang chạy đua rồi mới đã thể
xa và bỏ xa mình rồi các hướng chứ không
quan trọng Mỗi người có một cái kiểu tổ
chức tổ chất riêng nó bạn có người tiến
nhanh có người tín chậm mà có người kiểu
dạng là rẽ nhiều hướng các từ được như
tôi là tôi linh hoạt Nếu mà tôi So sánh
tôi với nhiều anh em lập trình viên khác
thì tôi sẽ thấy da tôi khá là kém Bởi vì
ở tôi không chuyên Hẳn là không rành
thuật toán lắm kiểu bây giờ bị lừa toàn
đấy Đấy xong rồi lý thuyết để tôi thì à
bộ phim set làm thế nào tôi yeah Tôi vẫn
đang phải học cũng tương đối thôi nhưng
mà còn nhiều anh em thì có thể chuyên
sâu hơn rồi giờ thứ đấy thì nếu mình so
sánh công thứ Thế thì mình sẽ luôn cảm
thấy xấu hổ kiểu gì mình chẳng thua thứ
nhất mình luôn hôm con nhà người ta ở
thứ hai mình mình còn bị chậm vì mình là
ra ra ngoài đi làm thực tế muộn so với
nhiều người ấy thì chắc chắn là mình
mình sẽ kiểu gì sẽ thua một vài đứa rồi
loạn
Ừ mình nếu so sánh mình với quá khứ để
mình tiếp tục phấn đấu có thứ thôi mình
thứ nhất mình phải luôn biết được mình
yếu điểm gì cái chắc chắn ưu nhiều của
mình như nào xong mình cứ phấn đấu thôi
sau khi so sánh cái gì so sánh cả ngay
khi ngựa từng nói cái đấy rồi mày ạ
nhiều tội Mới chia sẻ rồi nhưng mà ơi
thì tôi sẽ nó lại riêng Bạn sao vậy
ở top top là cái gì Ý tôi là Tik Tok
Ok mấy ông bây giờ không có hỏi đáp thì
tôi cơ tạm hôm nay tạm nghỉ nhé dép lốp
thì có nhiều người bây giờ thường ai
thương sẽ nhất rồi và bảo nó xu thế thì
tôi lại không chuyên được cái đấy Và tôi
cũng không ý định chuyên về rồi đấy tôi
hướng định hướng và tôi sẽ là futech
theo kiểu là
em biết ơi review lại nhưng mà hơi ga
phải Sáu vẫn hứa với Bác em nhiều hơn
này bác em là ở đây cụ thể là ngôn ngữ
lập trình thì không quan trọng lắm mà
quan trọng nhưng tôi hướng về bên atwell
thứ gì kiểu FB neckwear này ở thiết kế
thiết kế thiết kế sử liệu thì càng tốt
ai và vì sao lâu dài hơn thì có thể lên
làm ít theo kiểu nhưng mà sẽ là cậu định
hướng kiểu mình có kinh nghiệm về bài 8
nghĩa vụ cũng như về em về equal có thể
về sau lên và bia cũng được tha thứ
Ừ Thế định hiếm về công nghệ thông tin
tôi như thế
Ừ tôi không nha không muốn nhảy sang bên
đẹp óc
à à
không ai hỏi gì nữa thì thôi nhỉ
à Tôi đang xuống mũi và cha tôi sẽ nghỉ
tí không không nói mấy đứa à
Ừ Ok mày ông nha
số thứ thứ Năm nha từ năm thì tôi sẽ bắt
đầu hồi chữa về ạ
thì tài liệu nói cho họ bất cứ nhóm là
mà muộn nữa muốn bảo vệ các thứ thứ Thì
cư cứ bình luận để mà hôm sau bảo vệ nhá
i-mobile kết hợp với
tp002 nên dùng Mobile fpp đâu
dùng giả Ba đi mà
à à